una nueva escena de violencia en las
disjordania ocupada miles de colonos
marcharon hacia el asentamiento de
eviatar con el fin de presionar al
Primer Ministro israelí benjamine tanyao
a que autorice su repoblación tras
ordenar su evacuación en 2021 el
ministro de seguridad y tamar vengavir
conocido por sus posturas radicales
participó de la marcha junto a él
ministros y activistas que buscan más
asentamientos judíos en cisjordania
le llamamos la gran marcha de Qatar para
presionar al gobierno para que cumpla
con su obligación de construir este
asentamiento
se ha convertido en un símbolo para que
lo sigan muchos más
la movilización de colonos despertó la
ira de los palestinos en el monte
los colonos israelíes piensan que
regresarán al monte pero los habitantes
de beita nunca los dejaremos regresar a
esta montaña donde cayeron doce Mártires
y resultaron heridos cinco mil hermanos
la ONU es Clara en condenar la
ampliación de los asentamientos judíos a
los que considera ilegales cerca de
500.000 israelíes han ocupado sus
Jordania contra una población de 3
millones de palestinos cuyas familias
han habitado estas tierras desde antes
de la creación del Estado Israel en 1948
la escalada de las tensiones ocurre tras
una semana violenta con dos ataques uno
en sys Jordania y otro en tel aviv en
los que murieron al menos cuatro
personas y por la muerte de hoy de un
palestino de 15 años en una redada
militar en un campo de refugiados en
cisjordania y en medio de una
inestabilidad política en Israel debido
a la polémica reforma de justicia de
netanyahu
la violencia en 2023 ha dejado más de 90
palestinos muertos y al menos 19
israelíes
[Música]